to work with everybody i think requires
especially for this movie a lot of
different points of view encanto has
plenty of deleted scenes that make a
whole lot of sense and yet contain a
whole lot of nonsense at the same time
and speaking of nonsense we're also
checking out the bloopers
i just changed the whole movie for you
didn't know i could do that interesting
we honestly have no idea what to make of
this scene
in a very rapunzelesque moment isabella
sneaks out her window and goes into the
woods mirabelle thinks she's been
attacked by a wild animal but as it
turns out it's just a man dressed like a
big cat to scare off animals
most predators hunt by smell which is
why i covered it in the urine of several
animals and then isabella makes out with
the costumed man named bobo in front of
her sister
you saw nothing i wish i saw nothing
this scene honestly just seems like a
prank but the two were planning to run
away together presumably because of all
the pressure from abuela we're glad this
scene was cut as funny as it is removing
it made her plotline distinct from
dolores's
i couldn't really put words to or a
feeling to
what i saw
to love it all is to love entirely
this was originally
nearly the end of the movie when
mirabelle
devastated has left the family
originally mirabelle was going to run
much further than the river she was
going to run all the way back to the
city her abuela ran away from where she
would encounter the new world abuela
sits out on her own
she comes across a mural that says to
love it all is to love entirely she
finds mirabelle sitting on a bench with
nowhere to go and no idea what to do it
sounds like in this version julieta was
injured pretty bad too i couldn't bear
the thought of losing anyone else
the whole thing seemed a bit sad but we
love the idea of returning to where you
came from it's never the same after you
leave and even if it is it doesn't evoke
the same feelings within you well we
absolutely loved the movie it feels like
we waited the entire movie for a big
journey that never got past the river
keeping the family away from modern day
advancements was probably a good call
what do you think
i think that that's a testament to our
directors and what they're able to do
we wonder if isabella could bring
anything else to life or if it was just
potatoes you heard that right similar to
elsa with olaf isabella brought a little
cluster of potatoes to life we're unsure
what their use would have been in the
movie but they sure are cute they were
cut very early in the process for the
princess of perfection you'd expect
living flowers like in alice in
wonderland not potato people but who are
we kidding potatoes are perfection why
is it that isabella had the weirdest
cutscenes
allowed myself to have this opportunity
you know it's not easy to be here and to
get here honestly you could never
convince us that mopping is more fun
than talking to jaguars mirabelle gets
stuck cleaning the house with her
non-magical dad and uncle hey forget out
there this job in here is the most
special we get a little peek of dolores
room but at this point in the story
she's the character who healed with food
not the mom
and peppa doesn't control the weather
she has indestructible powers still
alive
[Music]
we kind of actually love the development
of the fathers in this scene because
we've been wondering how it would feel
to be these two married into a family of
magical people their total devotion is
heartwarming and we learned that bruno
only got his name because lin-manuel
miranda came up with the lyrics to we
don't talk about bruno on the spot
yeah it was amazing
so his original name oscar was dropped
oh also his room wasn't a sandy cave at
first either his room turned all rotten
gross and sand doesn't rot so we just
put two and two together he just created
a safe space for me to be as weird as
possible honestly we would have loved to
see this scene in the movie mirabelle
and antonio were going to go on a jungle
trip together to get into bruno's room
as the original entrance was blocked we
felt antonio pretty much got snuffed out
of the movie after he got his powers
this deleted scene shows us exactly why
we feel this way but what we love about
the cutscene is it gave us great
perspective into how the rooms work i
think you have like the coolest room
however it created a much more
mysterious feel to go through the sand
rather than take a different route
through antonio's room
but we are much happier with the way
they set up luis's song in the end catch
her before she cracks not after and also
mirabelle's prying added way more to the
stakes of the scene eventually i'm gonna
sing you a song right here yeah that's
right
luis has a softie under the surface her
room never wound up in the movie but
that's okay because we definitely got
hints of it with the unicorn donkeys
don't believe us the concept art from
luisa's room showed that she might have
had a secret door to escape the pressure
of her family
while the obvious choice for a room was
a gym
or one that was made purely out of stone
it's that secret gateway that led to a
theme park that really piques our
interest
everybody needs an escape sometimes
right
oh you're gonna make me drop a donkey
they're playing a game of musical chairs
with superpowers the characters powers
bounced around the family a lot before
they landed on who worked best with what
peppa and a fire-powered character named
fuega merged with each other there were
twins named amelia and sophia amelia had
an aura that made everyone fall in love
with her but her sister sophia had an
aura that repulsed everyone given we
already have bruno and mirabelle who
feel unappreciated it's probably good
they didn't have a third outcast you see
you're missing the point
the fate of the family it's not up to
her it's up to you
there was also a guy whose personality
may have merged with camilo that of the
pool playing trickster princessa has
concept art similar to that of isabella
so she didn't make it past the cutting
room floor there was also a character
named zoe who could speak with
technology but when she was sleeping
that technology didn't like to do its
job
miranda may have been an earlier version
of antonio as she seems to be holding a
rabbit she may have been an early
concept of mirabelle's mother giving
julieta the power of healing through
food allowed for she and her daughter to
bond in a special way i wish you could
see yourself the way i do
you are perfect
just like this
yes the madrigal family is much
different in concept than what we saw on
screen just goes to show how hard they
worked at giving all of the characters a
power that reflects their place in the
family but also their place in the
storytelling
no two characters are alike in any way
we were saved
because of you
and it's time for some bloopers
we're so used to stephanie beatrice
playing rosa we can't get over how
adorably charming she is we were so
distracted by that we forgot to tell you
she's not saying the line as scripted
when i saved the miracle when i saved
the miracle when i saved the miracle
after i saved the miracle
first gift ceremonies are so magical you
forget what to say first gifts first
first gifts ceremony set set uh ceremony
ceremony ceremony it's nice to see that
the actress behind abuela can get a
little silly
miracle blessed eat with them
let's eat each wither
the miracle blessed each with a magic
gift to help us
proof that voice acting is really acting
and maybe the biggest challenge since
you're playing pretend all by yourself
i make the speckle yeah it's it's hard
to say
i made the sparkle make the sparkle
how did he do that if bathrooms had
better sound proofing voice over actors
would probably record from the toilet no
joke they are constantly drinking water
you guys need to go to the restroom i
know that as well i've been going to the
bathroom this whole time that feel when
your father doesn't know how to say your
name am i saying mirabelle or mirabel
what am i saying i forgot am i fighting
or hugging
help us out is this an acting choice or
is he warming up his face muscles
to make the candle bright you have to
embrace your embrace
and embrace and embrace
why so intense
the answer is
no they weren't expecting you to sing
but
we liked it anyway please don't clap
thank you oh it's nothing
[Music]
i don't know if you wanted me to sing he
must have jinxed himself
into the mic that would be an
interesting way of recording wouldn't it
what does it mean
is it why you came back or
we understand why these scenes didn't
make the final cut introduced audiences
to this character who just so happens to
be who he is but it was nice to get a
glimpse into how the magic rooms work
you got this
just gonna save the miracle
and it was all made 10 times more fun
with the inclusion of our voice actor
buddies
[Applause]
[Music]
do you think any of these scenes should
have been left in let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching
[Music]